so I've previously mentioned that
there's a lot of maths in Futurama and
I'm gonna show you two more bits of
maths from Futurama there's an episode
called The DaVinci Code where the the
Planet Express crew are investigating a
mystery around the Last Supper they
think there may be a robot a sat around
a table as one of the Apostles and so
they go to a future Roma as they call it
and they're in a crypt and they find
this tomb with this mysterious Roman
number on it was not a number and it's
not a date either really it looks more
like a Roman mathematical equation look
at these Roman numerals so to understand
what this is all about we need to look
at their sin numbers so I'm sure they're
same numbers have cropped up previously
on numberphile but just to remind you a
Mersenne number father Mersenne was a
parisian monk who would correspond with
lots of other mathematicians and he came
up with this number which is of the form
2 to the power of P minus 1 where P is
prime and so let's put in some prime
numbers 2 to the power 2 minus 1 is 4
minus 1 is 3 let's put in another prime
number to the power 3 minus 1 is 8 minus
1 is 7 2 to the power 4 were not
interested in because that's not a prime
but 5 minus 1 is 8 16 32 that would be
31 if we take away the 1 2 to fire 6
were not interested in seven is a prime
32 64 128 that's a hundred 27 next prime
is 2 to the 11 now one thing you'll
notice about these two three xi minus 1
so that is 2 4 8 16 32 64 128 256 512
thousand 24 2048 minus 1 is 2047 so
these are called mass n numbers ok and
we put in a prime here and bang at the
other end we get a prime a prime a prime
and a prime
now this one okay this is a bit tricky
actually this one it's hard to tell
whether on it's a prime but at first
sight this seems to be a pretty good way
of generating primed and actually is a
very good way of generating primes but
it's not foolproof and in fact the first
number the first mess said number that's
not a prime is this one here 2047
because 2047 equals let me have a look I
mean it from memory it's 23 times 89
okay so this mayor said number is not on
there send Prime and this equation is
kind of embedded up here because if we
translate from these Roman numerals what
we've got is 2 to the power 11 minus in
brackets 10 23 multiplied by 50 60 70 80
90 minus 1 is 89 ok and 2 pair 11 we
know is 2048 we know that this is 2047
so this minus this equals a 1 so what
we've got is is the kind of a mess n
number here which is not a mess M prime
which is why it's kind of a little bit
interesting encoded on this 2 in this
tomb in future Roma in Futurama in Roman
numerals so that's one of the things
that if you're watching the episode you
can't think it's a funny story it's an
interesting story
typical Futurama but hidden within it is
this weird mathematical reference which
you'd only get if you pause it freeze
frame it unpack the math and then you
figure out what's happening indicate how
many places we need to take it 1 okay
we're there they love math and and
they're not mathematicians anymore and
and that this is just their way of
expressing that love of math I'm not
super familiar with how animation shows
are made but I've seen bits and pieces
and I know these guys are obviously
sitting and writing scripts in a
brightest room other people actually
drew the drawings and the animations
yeah this is not germane to the story in
any way so today this put like a note in
there saying if there's a gravestone
make sure you put this number on the
side or how do they communicate
they do they they write it in detail
that you know this is this is every
aspect of what they want in the scene I
remember the very one the very very very
first episode of The Simpsons first kind
of real episode in Simpsons there was a
joke about calculus and they get it
wrong on the blackboard the maths is
actually not correct and I think that
was an example where they scribbled out
two math they sent it off to be animated
and whoever was doing the animation
didn't really appreciate how important
the mathematical detail was and there's
an error but I think ever since then
they've been very careful with what
their mathematical instructions are and
they're very very careful to check them
afterwards as well no doubt so yeah in
an episode called the honking where the
Futurama crew go off to a spooky castle
for the reading of a will and it's all a
bit scary and they're walking through
this castle and then suddenly blood
appears on the wall zero one zero one
one zero zero one zero one okay so this
binary sequence in blood it's on the
wall all a bit scary so let's find out
what this binary sequence is in deaths
and more we've got a 1 2 4 8 16 32 64
128 256 ok so if we add these up we've
got 537 101 357 okay that equals 357 357
is not a particularly interesting number
as far as I know it doesn't scream out
as being a perfect number or Mersenne
Prime or any of those interesting
numbers we come across sometimes but
then bender the robot turns around and
he sees the number reflected in a mirror
and so the binary digits are switched
around
so let's have a look at this binary
sequence now if we reverse the digits we
now have a 1 Oh
100 1 101 oh ok so we can now translate
that binary sequence back into decimal
we've got a 2 no fours we've got 8 16 32
64 we're going to 128
no 256 years and a 512 2 & 8 10 10 16 to
26 26 and 128 is 154 154 and 512 is 6 6
6 / the number of the devil the number
of the beast as a bender he's just
completely terrified and he runs away
screaming but why so much love about
this is it it's never explained why
bender is so terrified the only way that
you the viewer will ever understand
what's happening is if you the viewer
while you're watching it can do the
binary to decimal translation in your
head on the fly in half a second
otherwise it doesn't make any sense so
that's the level of mathematical kind of
a trivial it's kind of embedded in this
program
if you enjoyed this video and would like
to hear even more from Simon well you're
in luck because he's the special guest
in the most recently released episode of
the numberphile podcast you can find it
on your podcast player of choice you can
also go to the numberphile website or
you can listen via YouTube on the
numberphile to channel there'll be links
on the screen and down in the video
description